you
hey yeah where we are back for another
Friday games review and yes we dropped a
massive amount of money on video
equipment this week almost none of which
works but actually no we see the video
card the video ingestion cards we have
which is a black magic deck link quad is
working awesomely it's so much better
than the USB stuff we had we picked up a
bunch of hdmi to SDI converters for our
devices and quickly found that hdmi is
the devil's connection but it absolutely
is you know we we didn't realize that in
fact our HTML ASD I cards would not
actually properly negotiate a signal
with our with our devices so we're gonna
have some really you know I call them up
to and they're like why should we
negotiate exactly yes so so so we're
learning but you know hopefully it's not
going to completely suck today we we
certainly are excited about the new
camera that we're using this week and so
we used it last week that's what we do
use it last week yeah but you weren't
here I wasn't here so that's that and in
my mind you're not here this week either
because the most important part of you
is missing I know I know my coat are you
the beard sorry and you'll notice that
in an effort to cover for Dan I have
been growing this thing since um last
episode and yeah this is what I get
after a week's worth of growth I was
actually going to demonstrate what
happens to Dan after a week's worth of
growth but I couldn't actually find a
royalty-free picture of Charles Manson
so so the yes we both have half of you
today i was i hope i hope this doesn't
make anyone disappointed out there also
i did want to note that i did go to
green bay last week for memorial day and
i will say green bay really does know
how to celebrate Memorial Day properly
it was a solemn and beautiful occasion
and so I am wearing this cheese hat and
yes it's not a full cheese head but wait
if that's your cheese had you really
feel maybe I'll wear my cheese hat and
I'm like well I also might I know you
you you're gonna pick up cheese down
that's not a cheese hat that's a hat
with a picture of cheese on it that's
true that's true so it's so I actually
if there's a demand i will actually wear
a real teeth hat it also i just want to
say i don't think the viewers at home
can see this but on the back it says
1995 NFC central champions as it is like
the least important gonna be like are
they still stuck in the past is that
what's going on i got i got this hat
from someone who'd been collecting it
for a long time so so yeah that's that
said that was like their glory days 1995
oh my dearest was was to thousands you
know the why'd you buy I know where it
is yeah right all right all right go
young girl cry let's get to the pier so
today we're drinking and east ringing i
I've been minus two over the other side
of the road Trevor I can you can you get
Dan's beer please yeah our perfect
coming from treasurer John's by the way
is I is engineering for us today which
means that Android probably won't ship
on time you take you to my our out of
traversal gradual nothing's going to
happen at Google i/o this year because
trevor is now working with us and so
Trevor basically does all our jobs
anyway so we are drinking sanctification
sour blondes today and it's one of those
fancy ones its bottle fermented comes in
a champagne cork there we are whoo happy
Friday everyone happy friday Cheers mmm
laughter others dad is a sour ale
absolutely well after all the stress of
having everything not work this week all
week long it's really nice to settle
down and have i literally spent all day
yesterday trying to get our HDMI set up
to work I finally found that if we
plugged our old HDMI set up into the new
one and told it because the old one had
the ability to set the format so if I
told it what format I don't want to be
and then unplugged it and quickly
plugged in the other one it would
remember so it's sort of this like
homeopathic format settings yeah oh you
know this is
this is it again it's it's a why we love
hdmi so much thank you electronics
industry so in any event we should
probably get on to looking games well I
do want to say one more thing maybe we
should we should probably warn everyone
that we have no portrait mode so
basically if the game's not in landscape
we're pretty much screwed hdmi wives
yeah well does this actual business
camera on the camera works does work
okay so so what will be going old school
should be showing you actual it's all we
had last week that's right one the
really good thing about the new hdmi box
so is the frame rates twice as high
awesome so hopefully we'll be able to
see some gay i well it looks like it is
anyway you want to see yeah it should be
it should be hopeful you would
appreciate the smooth animations on on
our transformer prime here that we're
yeah that it's been I test mule if you
don't mind me saying though my god this
viewer is really good yes I wish I'd
gotten more of it I know it's just great
it's um well yeah well it's a little on
the expensive side oh yeah but you know
seriously what I think worth it giving
all that all the couple with you put in
this read all the extra hours just I
think I think you've earned this beer
well I have a philosophy it's you know
how rich are you like so like if you're
I don't know is Zuckerberg for instance
right with his famous pig right um you
know you're asking can I afford this
island you know right right um and you
know if you're if you're really well i
like better off than I am your be like
yeah you know this car you don't have to
care right exact like a rich enough not
care about car or house right exactly
right so I'm just rich enough to not
care about beer like I don't look at the
price like do I want to drink this beer
I'm gonna drink this beer that's but we
are rich enough not to get a bit of a
wine from when George Washington was
still alive that's that's that that's
kind of our death that's where we drew
the line towards your the wine yes well
you know it was a Madeira and and a
three-hundred-year-old Madeira is really
just getting started that's right we
wouldn't want to drink it ahead of its
time alright so let's let's take a look
at what we have today we're actually
look at seven games I wanted to start by
relooking at some actually we're gonna
go in reverse chronological order let's
don't know I think you're right i think
we should we should revisit okay so
we're going to have to we're going to
have to go into camera mode here
because again we do not have hdmi for
portrait stuff and x bugs is a portrait
game so there we are aha no I was right
the first time alright so yay so here we
are old school I guess I should try to
we're going to use our old fashioned
zoom here there you are Wow yeah i know
this is exciting so this was great so we
actually looked at x bugs on the show a
few weeks ago and you really were really
like the game thought it was a really
clever take on on the bug squashing
genre which I guess exists now but uh
but but what on tablets you really left
something to be desired so the developer
came back and said to us this week we
nominate the title said hey look at all
the cool stuff we've done and I will say
the game looks beautiful I mean it
really really does look beautiful you
can see the menus are all really high
resolution you can especially see since
we're zoomed in here but you know they
you know it looks looked really really
sharp on this display oh how close can
we get I know I was a little ramp by
there can we see the pen tiles almost
wow yeah that's not it this is an LCD so
we have full resolution on this guy
really yeah I know I know that's why it
looks so good alright so to kind of
pocket a little bit about about this
game if you if you've played any of
these kind of bug squashing news before
you'll know talking about almost all the
graphics have actually been upgraded in
the game to high quality and to this
resolution which is really cool I'm the
only thing I really wanted to point out
is that you have to really be careful
with these kinds of games that you look
at every place that the back he can be
hit so first of all we're right now in
the middle of the game and we get the
option to quit and what did that happen
I mean it seems like we could have just
gone back one screen absolutely so this
is an example of you know of something
that you know our reviewers would
actually catch now admittedly we're in
sort of a tutorial mode so that's sort
of understandable but i'll show you the
the big thing is if we're if we actually
go here we bring this up and now the
back key doesn't do anything anymore and
and you know so it we've gone like
halfway yeah and and the idea is the
back you should always do something
anyway I mean by do something I mean
navigate somewhere I don't mind pop up
something that says the back key doesn't
work here which I we've seen before I
mean better than nothing all right we
don't you know there's there's
pause for effort there but I but not
sure that it's better than nothing it
might well at least at least the user
gets some sort of notifications that pop
up something are you sure you wanted an
Android device yeah exactly I mean why
is why would you ignore like one of the
most important features of Android so
that's at you know the menu still there
but that's it's really i think more more
result of the fact that they're using
openfeint and open taint requires than
any key to do settings but by the nation
which by the way you will still get
dinged on and I you know we we love the
openfeint guys um but you know they're
not they're not moving super fast on
this one yeah well they're you know they
have a new platform and so yeah
there.that III think i think it's going
to get better but i think that for right
now you know if you you know buyer
beware with your with using open fan you
know that that you're gonna be stuck
with these these legacy menus unless you
can rewire the interface yourself and i
think actually you can i think you
actually can't put a direct link into
the settings within your app within
their api because they basically give
you a lot of that stuff so well that
would make a lot of sons yeah so any
case I you know think about that when
you're using these libraries alright
that's I just wanted to get that was X
bugs it's very cool I think that with a
few of those back key issues fixed that
it's definitely something that that the
editorial of you cumin did you agree
that it was less difficult by the way
what the hexbug levels cuz that was one
of the things they tried to do right oh
I don't know I should have looked I
actually I actually didn't play it that
long i mostly looked to say all right
graphics are good played like three
levels and then that was it so but you
played three levels that's cool i
couldnt get the best first one so so
that was x bugs we're going to go in
sort of we had this idea here that we
were going to go in reverse
chronological order based upon win the
game should have been written right
obviously we have to start with space
Defense we actually have the developer
of spaced events live on our hangout I
believe that we write about that they
had intended to come on you know this is
another game that there's only portrait
so we're gonna have to switch once again
to camera number two or three or four
whatever whichever one it is there we
are now this is actually good night
because you can see the whole game here
because the rest of it is really just a
picture of a legacy phone device and an
really this this this by the way was was
my favorite phone for quite a long time
and I I still sort of feel that that
nakia never Beverly yeah that's a nokia
what 5900 i think was it was well it's
very similar to the 5900 what I was like
if you've ever seen that successively
collect baseball cards or hey Dan is
like that with mobile devices and GPUs
that's that cyclopedia memory so any
case what I loved about this particular
device is this was like the last non
whap device that Nokia did and after
this device they had to redo tool their
whole UI around whap so they could get
soft keys and there you I started to get
a lot less intuitive so that being said
I looked at this game and I tried to
figure out you know how to use them i
realized i had to use it exactly like
you know a nokia phone even has the
numbers for the venues so it's a very
nice emulations of go to experience you
know definitely you need to make sure
the back key works even if you're
emulating especially since that's what
the clear key does so come on guys and
if you're gonna if you're going to go
all the way to emulating the device at
least make the regular Keys emulate the
keys that are on the screen so that's
that would be my my only my only take on
this is that you know it's a it still
needs to behave like an Android app even
if you're going to this level and it
wouldn't be hard so now that is if you
played the original game you know which
you I you know as far as i can tell i
think i played this game maybe once you
actually yeah the finding the original
game doesn't actually use the keys as i
recall so we're stuck using how I fire
again Aereo yeah it's like one in four I
think oh yeah I accidentally hit the
back of the kid DC key but that's what
that's what the game is up and you know
I for those of you who are really into
nostalgia you will probably love this
game it was probably you know the best
game I think made for this device that
ping said you know I probably not
insanity this was released once I
actually you know that's a good question
i don't know when this game was a
release but maybe the developer would
can tell us a bit about it it certainly
was released when mobile phones were a
thing right it's not like you're yeah
not in that like huge brick get through
it i'm cold you want to phone you know
i'm trying to think of this game was
just pre loadings i don't think they
even had a store to buy stuff so i think
Kings pre-loaded on some devices right
but i don't i'm not i'm not sure i
wonder where the original developer this
game is I don't know there's got to be a
story there there does it does but
anyways it's actually really fun and you
know it's great to see an emulation you
know obviously or you know this
simulation is what we call this I don't
it's not something i think that the vast
majority of android users would be
really excited about but there's you
know i'm sure there is a contingent
that's going to be really excited about
this game are we do we have the the
developer on the Hangout kind of i'd
love to hear more about it yes yes no
excellent sweet this is great usually we
don't have anybody on our hangout hahaha
like why aren't you using the other
weapon of course now we get to test our
audio system and see if we can actually
hear oh that's a good point on every
week after this before okay stop playing
the game come on sorry it is fun okay
can we hello is this christian ah i'm
not the one about this game I'm did he
went above coke it doesn't miss oh well
there you go so is it is there another
dude online no let's go over to get
albany on a couch and we'll go ahead
where this will go out of our order that
things were and actually we can go into
into no this is another that's right is
another another one week was weak when
yeah we're was our week of portrait
games you know it's a hot so I I had a
lot of fun with this game and you know
it's it's it's a physics game kind of
probably the only thing about this game
that really struck me is being really
odd when I started playing it and it was
was that I really wasn't used to a
cannon being a slingshot and I spent
about five minutes going like wait i
tipped the cannon and it's doing exactly
the opposite of where I want the count 0
the must be up to ya so this is this is
this is this is sort of the angry cow
game and then I realized oh it's
actually a slingshot so um I think that
if one wants to make it work like a
slingshot once you probably make it look
like slingshot but that was my you know
I I like the idea that cow actually kind
of turns into the Canada that's fine
well if you had any sort of you know
like uiq like I've seen games put like a
little
on the back or something like that
because I've seen you know other games
have this same effect you know and they
don't necessarily have a slingshot but
that you know that you've got to give
the user some hue as to what's going on
yeah I did I did spend about about 30
seconds and it's funny because I
actually understood how the game was
supposed to work and then I spent about
30 seconds because it almost works you
know I'm like well why I'm trying to
shoot forward so I keep spinning around
here eventually it'll become oh I just
killed my cow um anyways I am sort of
wondering you know I I take it that
you're not from these parts and I'm
wondering which parts you are from where
cows turn into cannons when they land
that threw me for a loop oh I'm from
Austria and animal you know no say no
more oh you know warranted cows yeah
that's that that's going yes that's all
we needed out yeah absolutely so tell us
it tell us about the the making of this
game did you have a large team is it
just you what how do you go about it um
we have two people a friend of mine and
me and the game we developed about two
years ago it was self first attempt to
do an android game actually so how did
you find it did you run into any any
serious issues or was it easy well
actually it was easy to do I look Sarah
I mean we had only one test device so
review oh it's not working on my device
yeah we couldn't do that there are two
people and with one device only the user
review helped us so what kind of things
that users report and what kind of
things did you know easy were they to
fix when you went when users kind of
said hey it's not working on my device
one problem was from the thought she
went because some mobile phones always
via the track event and we use trek to
move around the camera so they couldn't
click and we had to fix that to an
offset that's in the galaxy s it works
perfectly but on htc it just didn't work
it was easy to fix but you have to know
it so that was and that was inside of
the gesture detector then that you're
that you were saying that is that we're
using a that as your to determine
whether you were dragging yeah were you
using gesture detector or were you just
consuming touch events raw touch events
yes it's handmade that it gets to the
addiction okay okay interest interesting
yeah we said that's I you know it's
usually in theory all of our UI is using
gesture detection so that same way
that's a or not all of it a lot of our
UI is using a brother that's your
detector so I'm curious you know there
are pieces in which in which we actually
go up into our own thing I think we're
listed a few other things we may be
using other doctors but usually that's
that's how we determine whether we're
touching or dragging so I'm kind of
surprised and then you are using scale
just a detector to do to do the
multi-touch scale or are you using or
are you consuming the events and doing
at yourself oh we get the two ends from
its GTX ah and so so we get there the
events and coordinates and well we
calculate every friend hello yeah the UI
it's really smooth I'm impressed by that
yeah it looks it looks really good i
mean the one the one by one comment on
the scaling was that is that the scaling
isn't a focused or on the point in which
you're in which you're pinching so like
how would that was my one thing i
noticed like and when I in theory if I
go up here and I pinched it should
actually scale around that point and
it's actually scales around the center
of the screen that was that would be my
only comment on the pin zoom it'd be
cool or if it did that but yeah the game
works really really well runs great on
the transformer prime what device did
you test this on if you found my if I
may ask we did sit alone samsung galaxy
s no.1 transformer one ok and Nexus
something which nexus one phone samsung
galaxy oh the new one galaxy nexus ok
cool because the prove the nexus s was
also from samsung yeah exactly we're up
that's what I'm carrying so cold why you
know god I don't really know what else
to say as far as far as a navigation you
know I this this is this is exactly
doing you know exactly what I would want
it to do I only the only other the only
thing I was thinking is it might want to
see the title screen before I get went
back here and said we come back to here
and hitting back here goes it exits that
was my only my only real comment about
the navigation other that it looks good
you know there aren't any there isn't
any background music so I don't really
have a problem there's no real problem
with that so you know as far as far as
that goes on and then you know it's just
a question of you know the layouts
actually the layout work looks really
good on tablets now it looks fine on
phone so I think from that perspective
it's looking really good to running
really well yeah it's a really great
game that in that respect I think
there's you know the one thing that I
wanted to point out that I think you
might want to consider is just the the
art style and and the the art of the
game is so well done and I'm certain
it's deliberate but you know I'm a
little concerned about the just all the
sharp edges we see here especially when
you've got the floating islands I don't
know if there are any on this level or
not I don't think there are can we go
back to where we were before moon did i
did i lose ya wait Oh does this not
swipe no no okay yeah I sort of expect
this to swipe actually yeah maybe this
yeah that's why oh that's why what I
y-yeah yeah so this okay those are some
nice animations I like that yeah yeah
it's really so so when you're in the
beginning okay you can see these these
floating islands here have these really
really sharp edges on them we um and to
me that's just one of those things that
sort of says hey you know maybe maybe
didn't spend a whole lot of time on this
part of the art but you obviously did
spend a lot of time on other parts of
the art so it's it's a shame that that
particular part doesn't seem as polish
yeah these edges here especially the
other thing I was going to say it'd be
really cool to see a couple of some
animation on the on the cow itself like
I think I think you've got a cute little
character there be cool to see his eyes
roll or something how r him do something
you know that's true roll round no it is
kind of funny that he just rolls around
so you have to balance the comedy of
that but I think it'd be kind of cool
dad
do you know have a couple little
behaviors thrown in there yeah that's
well that's a advice that we give a lot
because we noticed that games where
there's a lot of animation on the main
character tend to do better because
people begin to develop an emotional
attachment to that character yeah so we
will put on our psychologist at here and
i think exactly you know it's that it's
that but yeah I think is I think it's
true and so that's always always
something we do saying you know it's
it's been it's been pretty consistent we
think it's part of the reason why
certain games like cutthroat and angry
birds are actually as successful as they
are is because they really have spent a
lot of time on those characters even
though Angry Birds has just a smallest
amount of animation it's actually mostly
the way in which they move the kit move
the birds around you know it's not it's
not even it's not even it's not even
eight frames of animation instead it cut
the rope is like it's it's so
manipulative it's almost porn I I didn't
actually understand the the draw I've
cut the rope until I had a baby and then
you're like oh I see that that's a baby
and you've got to feed it and we're like
hardwired evolutionarily yeah I do that
exactly exactly it's definitely got that
that component going on well it's great
talking to you and congratulations on
the game and we had a lot of fun with it
and as I said my either said the one
thing I would say is be really cool I
kind of felt that the you know the
mechanic would work just as well if I if
I thought of as a cannon rather than a
slingshot but um you know that would
that would be my only the only thing I
really you know had had any kind of
issue with in terms of in terms of the
controls so who actually fault it's
easier because everyone is playing angry
birds exactly sure yeah I think I think
it's my worms background I think that's
the problem maybe so my my my team one
team you know no obviously it's
something to get used to very quickly so
I did not not a big deal all right well
thank you for coming and joining us and
for in for nominating your app it's
great it was a great to have a chance to
play it yep thanks a lot here okay um
alright so thanks to Christian for for
that cow I you know it's funny because i
want to say cow clicker but it's not is
not a cop licorice anything without a
launcher yeah
it's a very different yeah but so let's
let's talk about something that says
space defensive all is is sort of like
the 90s trying to be the 70s and this
next one is a very modern game but it
brings to mind a genre that was popular
back in the in the early 90s which is
the sort of really super complex mm oh
of course you see a lot of the
eve-online and that sort of thing yeah
it's that complex it's like it's what i
would call almost a complicated web MMO
like yeah like you know this is this
just you the interface for this thing is
really designed you could run it through
anything that can do kind of you know
state you know state changes you know
the graphics that it has are really
there just to provide some color they're
not actually part of the game you know
they're there are there some fixed
graphics are actually part of the game
Trevor let's let's bring up that awesome
8 yeah we should say we finally have a
LAN stick game and we are going to use
it that's right there we are and this is
really impressive first of all just to
say you know it's it's all it's all 2d
art that's just that's just in a couple
of layers but it looks really high res
and there's there's some nice little
effect there with the you know the
blurring that's going on for the things
that are in front it just looks like a
little sort of a depth of field actually
almost feels like got the field even
though all it is is that it's just
blurry and fry the house right it funny
and if you can see there's there's some
nice alpha bundy going on there as well
um and and you and i was like cool this
is going to make a space shooter game
and it's gonna be an MMO and i was so
excited i was like and then I and I and
I started playing the game and did you
start playing the game did you figure
out the game yeah yeah yeah so they have
a tutorial button but the tutorial is
not for it's like a web yeah yeah it's
it's a website to log in with my account
name and password here so you all know
if you on the game you can see who i am
and hopefully it'll actually oh and by
the way oh wait I've got no network ha
so uh that makes this game a lot less
exciting so you know no max quit oh I
don't know um it's anyways I think we
might have to reboot the device I don't
know I want to actually get network um
no no we just need to turn Wi-Fi off and
on again okay it's a good point I got
one of these you
okay connect painting I connected see
how are you right you're right
absolutely well this we are we are on
google guest which is the world's most
complicated Wi-Fi network i think so and
we it's great for our testing purposes
because it constantly fails us so you
should we should have really really
robust Wi-Fi stacks to happen with this
i would imagine the amount of
electromagnetic radiation in this
building it is it okay yeah yeah we're
all do work that's what I that's right
alright so now and now I should be able
to actually log in to show you the game
so this game actor reminds me a little
bit of a game that I played it when i
was in college called multitrack yeah
yeah and and it's with sort of this
graphical overlay basically here is the
universe as we see it underlay wouldn't
you say yeah yeah and there's a so this
is this is this is our map of the
universe which is basically a bunch of
squares that we can travel to you so i
can say i want to go clear and i want to
jump to that square and you see it's
gonna it's going to give me i can go
jump three two one and now i'm working
through space there we are well that's
massive change to what's going on um
let's see wait I think I might have not
actually warped all the way let's try it
sets go gotta make multiple jumps here
so you so basically there we are now
we're warping you see you can see I'm
moving um oh wait there's pirates so I
can attack the Pirates I just tapped on
warp out and wait how are you going to
attack the pirate I tapped on I'm
totally clear up there in the corner you
see those are oh that yeah that's a
pirate oh no those are those are other
ships oh hi there was a part there but
he went away yeah tap on him yeah you
tap on him I think I even auto attack
him if you don't tap on him but you
definitely attack him when you tap on
him um and so yeah there we are you say
I've got 993 health left there's no one
in this is kind of boring but i can go i
think mind this metal wait wait you got
a very hard dude no oh no is that you
that was that's me yeah yeah that's not
I'm sorry Kay um so it was a Magic Flute
reference there oh wait street I've got
two week outlaws but I've got another
hey Ivan oh I guess he blew them up or I
just went to another I warped away I
don't know anyway so that's that's
basically the game there's all sorts of
other stuff you can do you can trade you
know it is this massively multiplayer
online game you do there are other
people playing it that you see and uh
but you know it's kind of a web game
what does kind of remind me of like Ned
track or it is little school muds it's
like this is obviously is the
programmers game and it just got built
up and built up and there's all kinds of
cool stuff attached to it yes um but
quite honestly if you're not already in
the community there's somewhat less of
an incentive to join yeah and I will say
you know this it's a difficult thing
this is actually this is an MMO it's
difficult to know what to do in the case
that you had like an incoming call so
well you know so here's what happens if
you let's head push the lock button here
we'll go back to our lock screen and
we'll hit the button again and go back
into the game as you can see the games
gone and that's because as soon as the
game locked it's a real-time game and so
it logged you out and closes right now
probably law you know probably logging
you out not such a bad idea you but you
know I mean you could be as you say I'm
in a sector I could be attacked right
now so it's kind of frustrating that
I've been logged on it doesn't try to
log me back in but I kind of understand
that well I don't know about that but
you know it's certainly not the most
user-friendly behavior well let's face
it you know if you're playing this game
if you're really into this get you're
going to hold all your calls you can
make it on that's right you're gonna
you're gonna you're gonna deseo incoming
calls and disable messaging and all that
kind of stuff probably be ya there so
that was that was one thing is it you
know from and that happens you know no
matter how the game is paused you know
you'll end up feeling of getting kicked
out of the game and it's kind of it's
kind of an interesting problem for any
kind of real-time game um this is not I
usually would say how to solve it you
know they're there are games that solve
this problem you know fairly well you
know the basic idea usually is that you
know you try to make sure if the user if
for some reason the user winks out of
existence on the network or the game is
going into the background you know the
usual thing to do is one on the game
side of thing you try to you try to
anticipate what they would have done you
have some sort of default actions I'm
going to enjoy to join his group and so
now member the untouchables very cool
here I'm here at the home world
and and that kind of stuff and then but
really getting user back into the game
as quickly as possible is usually what
you want to do because you don't want
this to be a barrier for someone play
your game you know like you want you
want to make sure that you know that I'm
that I like to take my call I get back
in boom I'm right there I might be
paused but at least i'm not i don't have
to do anything substantial right and
remember that mobile phones are supposed
to look magic you know mobile devices in
general you know they're they're running
multitasking operating systems with a
very very small amount of resources and
to the user they're supposed to look as
if they're just running everything and
everything's always smooth and
everything is always beautiful and i
think that you know we at Google have
had our own challenges with that I it's
taking a long time to evolve to where we
are but at this point yeah the the
operating system can support a lot of
really nice smooth magical behavior but
the application has to cooperate now
this in the other thing i would i would
comment about this you see you're
looking at the game we might want to
actually switch back to the game stroma
second was going to comment on the UI so
rana we're on a transformer prime and
you know tablets are interesting because
this is actually a ma mdpi device so
it's a medium density device and has a
fairly small default font and which is
actually kind of nice for this sort of
game you accept that the text is really
really tiny did you try this on a phone
though I did not it's impossible oh it's
so difficult yeah so this is this is
really a tablet only game at what were
you know what well you know I mean you
can play it but I think I would I
wouldn't want to learn our phone well
obviously obviously much information
there yeah I have to admit I did take me
about five minutes to figure out what I
was supposed to do is in the game even
reading through the tutorial which is a
website i would love to some because you
know you're interacting in real time
with other people nothing stops to let
you you know change your options or
whatever so Emma most tend to have a lot
of things on the screen because yes you
don't want to go modal yeah I think so
another thing like I would really love
to tutorial just to pull up webview like
I think that I think it would be because
the main problem is again it kicks you
out of the cute Oriole does pull up web
you know it pulls 00 a website puts you
into the browser
and so then what ends up happening is it
kicks you out of the game you hit the
backhand boom along and so oh so it's
ruining the experience really
interesting so it's hard it's hard to
believe that they're actually using
enough resources to justify think you
could really in the back key and so so
you know there's two that and I think
that's a pretty good way to end things
you know there's just a lot of lot of
really cool polish stuff that can be
done but you know I'm uh certainly I
know you guys are small teen and I
commend you on what you guys have done
and you know it's pulling this kind of
experience into Android into any kind of
mobile environment is not easy
especially something that's really
designed out a lot of text interaction
and and so this is you know really good
start but you know I think I think that
it can go you can just take this so much
further and I'd love to see you guys
continue to go on it I think you're
gonna have a you know there's always
going to be an audience for this kind of
game it is fun no question about yeah
it's really cool in it and I'm really
really impressed with what you guys have
been able to and they you know if you
look at their their market page that
their Google Play page that actually
says that they're supporting a small
team that's on this game alone which is
really impressive so great job so I want
to go to the next game which is another
game that is portrait so I'm going to
take this out rotate it and so that
we're ready on the next camera will try
to camera up again so lucky so this is
elemental jewels and elemental jewels is
actually a game which I am showing going
show you take a look at it running in
compatibility mode and the reason why
I'm running this in compatibility mode
is because this is actually one of the
first games we've used that is totally
unplayable if it's not in compatibility
mode which is a shame because the
graphics actually are very high
resolution look good but the frame rate
is so so disappointing on this device
that it's almost unplayable I was I was
getting just a couple of frames a second
playing the game and it made it really
really hard to play and also the text is
really really small so this is what is
one of those rare games in which it
makes it actually makes a lot of sense
to take advantage of some built-in
system features if you're not going to
actually go through and I optimize the
game around the tablet the easiest thing
for you to do is actually take advantage
of some of the features we have in
surface view if you're using the surface
due to compose things if not then my
recommendation is
is actually just to create a tablet
layout using some larger fonts that
really fits the screen but any case for
this particular in this particular case
actually going into patio volume mode
made the game much more playable so
we'll take a quick look at it it's very
it's very very smooth in this mode I can
I can show you what it's like when
you're running in the non compatibility
mode i'll switch to it in a minute the
objective is is this a jewel matching
game and this is another one of those
games in which which you have to be
really really careful about the back key
because it works in some places and not
another so right now I'm here and
hitting the back key does absolutely
nothing and you know what should it do
well it probably should take it back to
the screen before then so there's all
there's quite a lot of that in the game
when you actually get into the game
hitting the back key brings up the pause
screen that's cool when you hit the back
again and then nothing happens so you
know it's like it's sort of like halfway
there and you know and we can edit and
it's what we tell everyone we tell you
know all game developers go through and
make sure that on every single screen
even if the screen only comes up for a
second you know that the vaca does
something it's really really important
to the navigation feel normal so now I
have to go back to the screen and click
resume but the game itself as you see a
jewel match for kind of game your actual
goals you cease to get all these
percentages of jewels that you have at
the bottom of the screen and it's
totally fun and it's actually and then
and some of the jewels you actually get
by getting sets of things all these ones
at the bottom of the screen and there's
additional objectives you actually once
you've gotten through all of these
objectives at the bottom of the screen
then you actually have to go and collect
some special items that you have to
knock to the bottom that fall off the
end basically in order to in order to
actually finish the level so pretty it's
pretty game it's a pretty game and with
the or their power ups or their those
guys these guys take out rose you can
see depending on the order that takes
out a row this will take out an area so
those are those those are things that
the kind of help you I don't didn't
actually see any other sort of power-ups
but I could be wrong and I didn't play
the game extensively but I did play
quite a bit enough to know that it
didn't wanna play it in regular mode
let's go back to like what stretch to
fill screen now actually looks like
right okay so this is a the performance
we get in stretch evil screen first of
all the graphics are beautiful it's just
like they're really really high res but
the problem is that the game just slows
down to like an unplayable level of
slowness so I'm off yeah and so
yeah why is that Dad okay why I have
some theories I think that so there's a
gradient that's drawn behind the
background a very subtle gradient oh
yeah is that they're drawing the
gradient in real time rather than
drawing it once in caching that's my
theory but I actually don't know the
answer to that another thing that would
be great would be to see a real tablet
layout for this game on that it has some
larger font sizes because you can see
that they oh there's like there's a
couple they're just unreasonable
readable yeah yeah on a floating device
they're fine but on this device is
really really small and with the
beautiful high-res graphics that are
here you know that's what they was
easier guesses I didn't have a time to
really you know research extensively
what I do know is that even um turning
on hardware acceleration for this
forcing and did not actually help the
performance much it helped it a little
bit so but heard it in other ways so so
there's something there's something
that's going on that's clearly just
drawing like crazy and calculating like
crazy especially on this being a
transformer prime this is actually a
pretty fast device yes this is one of
those places where you might want to do
a little profiling yeah so so what I
usually do is use there's there's
actually a really cool thing you can use
called traceview inside of Android and
actually will show you all of your view
drawing and it's very very cool you just
turn it on and then it starts showing
you all of the draw calls that go
through and you can turn it off so
that's what that's what i would do is i
think this is done with our layout
system but i'm not sure you know that so
but if that's if that's what's going on
that may help a lot and you can look at
the timing of each one of your draws and
see how long it's taking so that that
would be my recommendation but other
than that I really like the game again
you know back key navigation is really
really important on this game actually
pauses when you go to the lock screen so
which is act which is a nice nice thing
for game to do it also automatically
eliminates the sound on lock screen
issue since it doesn't place out when
it's locked so another young sitting
place down with his paw what it's paused
as right all right when its paws that's
what I meant to say yeah and that is
always our recommendation is you should
pause the you know when you get a non
cause you should pause the game and stop
the music and then wait for the user to
restart it that way you you just dodged
all of the issues about is the phone on
is it you know is it in the right state
it has a lock screen gone away just get
rid of all and I actually think it's
differently from a user experience point
it's really good because even if even if
I now go and I and I've unlocked the
phone and I go back I don't have music
that's immediately blaring at me you
know that which is what I think I think
so I actually really like this
experience yet you always got to think
about the you know the user that has
been playing the game at the bus stop
and now they've gotten to work and they
pull the the device out of their pocket
and unlock it and what's going to happen
is are they going to get music is going
to be obvious they're playing video
games or is it the phone just going to
be in a state where where it's quiet so
this is actually one of the 21 of the
tricky things with layout view then I'll
show you is is it if you're doing the
kind of thing or you have a bitmap and
you're stretching it it's difficult to
set to say like maximum stretch you know
you end up with these in these guineas
in this particular game where we're
actually what you'd really like to see
is that elemental jewels title you know
doubled in size but we're only but we're
doing like basically you're setting but
the that particular layout to being just
fill parent and so it's going to and and
yet it's going to do it's going it's
going to be the height of the content
which is usually it's usually fill
parent and web content so you could do a
couple things that you could actually
set it you set it to two not wrap to
wrap content but set the maintain aspect
ratio flag which would look a little bit
better here on the bit map view that's
there assuming that's what it is you
know it's hard to tell when your whether
this is a real list or not but that's my
theory and and also again you know
justjust you see when you're when you're
on a tablet obviously this looks really
really small and having having some
large font sizes and a different layout
would really help it either way you know
there's really no excuse for this we
talked to a lot of people that are like
hey you know we we found just like the
left there right you know we had one
device to test on now we've got like
three or four but we're still going to
find these you know odd devices that
just don't meet our expectations but
this sort of layout issue is not a
device dependent issue it's dependent on
the screen size DPI the the OS version
and all of those things can be simulated
right inside of eclipse or IntelliJ or
anything else that uses our our layout
editor and you'll be able to you won't
catch everything but egregious issues
like this you will catch if you just
take the time to you know
click those drop downs and make sure
that you've actually taken a look at all
of the major types of devices and it may
not even be as comp you might not even
need a separate layup you might just
need some different sizes like you can
you can have you can have different size
different kind of minimum sizes for
different screen sizes in terms of
device to our density-independent pixels
and and that might be enough for this
kind of game to make just fix all these
things and make it look fairly smooth
across a wide variety of screen sizes so
it can be as simple as just literally
adding a couple of constants in you know
that say oh we're on a large screen
device therefore I want that the size of
my list item to be twice the size of
this default text yeah but you know the
fixes are simple the important thing is
just that you've done the testing you
make sure that you've seen your layout
at different sizes and I know you know
every time I do a layout this kind of
opinion it's not fun but at the same
time neither is finding out that you've
got a one-star review because you're
you're applic like like crap on some
device yeah anyway and the only way to
really test these kind of fill rate
issues is to is usually usually you'll
see them in the emulator first of all I
mean this kind of fill rate that were
issue that we're seeing here which I
suspect no we're talking about the
performance issues format yeah you
probably will see that in the emulator
if you choose a large screen I mean
that's that's because the emulator is
really really sensitive to those kinds
of issues because it's running an
emulation of our compositing system on
top of an emulation of OpenGL so you'll
you'll see usually use the frame rate
issues really really quickly unless
you're running the latest version or
emulator that's what you're going to see
so let's go on to the next title we're
almost done here so we've got a yeah
it's time for the lightning round it's
time for the line Aaron so you got spray
the wall and spray the wall I'm so
impressed that you got this to work huh
so um so my galaxy nexus wouldn't run
spray the wallet just went to a black
screen oh oh gee ok we can actually
switch to the hdmi think hopefully is it
up is that working check it out all
right excellence breathable first of all
awesome job on this on this menu I just
wanted to say I'm very cool yeah I like
him could be a little higher res for a
tablet like if you if you actually use
vector graphics for
uh so but yeah so you know again here we
I'd like to see I'd like to see larger
text sizes but you can you know you can
see it's very customizable and we're in
freehand mode so we can just weekend
free spray the walls and my biggest
thing about this was actually this is so
cool but from an interface perspective I
just thought that I'd be able to hit the
spray can and then spray on the wall
right is it feels like such a missed
opportunity and instead the way you
actually control it is you actually move
it like it was a joystick and then this
work here allows you to allows you to
control the sprang so you actually can
spray it's like a dual stigma like a
jewel stick game that's not even a
particularly good deals together that
stick is tiny yeah I think you know the
apartment is there is there is no what
switch back to the camera Trevor I just
want to show this really quick if you
can just get the cam view on the device
so the big broadcast there's two
problems yeah these this is the entire
range of the spraying you know that that
you know a lot of times we see things
that are way too big here and that's a
problem but in this case Wow way too
small well the problem is actually I
think that it's the right it's the right
size because it's actually size based on
the DPI like I don't actually mind this
Iseman the big promise is to right at
the edge and so if I go like this and I
pull off of it all of a sudden it loses
the fact that I'm trying to drag and it
doesn't have to but you've also got some
serious gimbal lock up there yeah so you
see what i mean so that's that's uh ya
know guy i ended up making called
quaternions look them up so you know but
other than that you know the gate i
think it's really cool concept i think
really the control is is was the issue
and you see like especially if the other
thing is if i'm sorry if i'm actually
going off the screen here you know it's
a question of what i really want to do
like if I'm holding it like this do I
want to note that I've gone off the
screen and leave it in that current
place or not I don't know but but this
is certainly the experience is pretty
bad from a usability perspective also
you can well and again I always catch my
little my tap see it didn't need to be
that way or I don't know I know it's a
lot of work I mean there's work involved
in actually you know saying I've touch
the screen here sure sure know what is
all the wall bin it's a map you know
that's it that's Lea you gotta do a raid
phrase yeah I mean it's you know it's
and that's the only two that's I would
say that's really but you know
he's probably doing the right choice
anyway to figure out where to put the
pain to the texture that's true he's got
this point here he knows he has to know
where that point is so that means if he
knows where this point is he probably
should be able to translate here and do
that point over there with the same map
well plus it's it's a really trivial
piece of map that's right I was right
yeah it's not difficult it's just yeah
and just have to do it yeah so I would
say really interesting concept it just
he definitely needs a little polish but
but the controls kill it yeah it needs
indeed the joystick the what you know if
you actually had a plug-in joystick it
would be awesome to have this interface
and actually and i think that with it
with an external joystick it'd be cool i
would keep this if the user how to
Joystiq plugged into it use the hid
interface read those axes that and that
would be great but if you actually don't
have a joystick plugin then yeah it's
got to be touch for this kind of game we
just make the game so much more fun and
top it would make it a lot easier and I
think maybe that's part of the problem
is that this is one of those games were
the challenges in the controls and we're
in freestyle mode you're not seeing the
game but also I it was a little tricky
to figure out which one of those was
actually back to the menu with the with
those little icons so that was a little
trick to you alright we're loading let's
go back to the just just to show you the
game itself is a really quickly since
we're in our in our last ten minutes and
I don't want to spend some time here so
the actual game is you're trying to
trying to trace these drawings & and
then so you can see you can see your
goal you have to get you have to use
multiple colors and then what in what
you end up getting is something that
looks like this so there's there's what
I have to actually trace and so you can
see if you could just draw with your
finger the game would actually be fairly
easy yeah so so that's I think the
problem with saying oh we should just
allow them to dry so so that's its but
again I mean this is what what Chris
Pruitt used to say right is it you
should be you should be fighting the
game not the controls if the game is all
about how crummy the controls are then
you know maybe your game design need
some thought absolutely yeah so that's
how you know my only my only thought on
that is I did you know it's it sometimes
you know designing the challenge around
the controls is not the best experience
especially lightning okay so here we are
so fight this last one is the last one
ahead love those guys yeah I you know
this I just want to put the screen on
this game this is this is a beautifully
beautifully done by one bad guy first of
all this is exactly how to give
character to a screen without actually
doing any work so he follows your finger
as you trace through the menu so they're
so awesome you know you no no no frames
of animation required here to do this
and it's just kind of a cool little
start to to what is really a quirky and
beautiful game design but notice also
that they didn't just trivial tribute
follow it it's got some physics to it
you know there's a lot of care taken to
make it yeah now the game is really
simple you actually play the game just
by using a touch in order to in order to
raise and lower your guys yeah and this
this is just a single touch yet but you
know the thing is this the sort of
single touch control has been done over
and over and over again but never quite
like this yeah so what you have to do is
you know then you have to tap things in
addition to the in addition to flying
the plane which is where it gets kind of
fun and complicated and the game is
actually really really deep very varied
there's quite a lot to do in the game
and I need a beautiful professionally
done game bye bye bye bye hothead you
know congratulations to them I actually
looked at this game to try to find bad
things about it and honestly you know
from from this is this is just a great
execution of the game design they had so
I I didn't have a lot of feedback to be
honest if there was anything about the
game but to work out you got to pick up
more zombies and then you can go infect
Portland yes that's the first that I
actually already infected Portland in
this game unfortunately uh so yeah you
can't you can't let what do you infect
next so you can let us i'm not going to
land in portland let's keep going
there's san francisco basically your
goal is to infect the entire United
States I think with zombies that's one
of the one of the goals in the game
there's a lot of varied things to do in
the game as you get further and further
along in the game there's a don't forget
to pick up your zombie parachuters man
oh did I knock out yeah exactly and you
say I got now I got a brain scratcher so
there's all sorts of things to buy in
the game this has all sorts of
interesting monetization things and not
everyone is doing so one of the things
they have this little scratcher things
that you can you can either buy or find
and they have the sort of guaranteed
scratcher this is a special item I can
follow this guy except i'm running in
two walls which isn't good into rocks
and stuff and there we are whoa big
prize so just lots and lots of stuff to
find in this game so all right oh that
was bad that was bad okay sometimes I
don't know what's bad already uh oh no
I'm all set a few wait me that's how it
makes me go up ha nice uh almost had a
few Oh Sees fuel every time you hit the
screen yeah well I didn't notice that
when i was playing though that's cool
how did you know but I'm already dead so
I guess I'm just dead again um that's
your plane is dead my plane is pressed
really yeah I'll idea what planes don't
rise from the dead that's true I've
ruined I've ruined my chance to him to
infect another city anyways honestly it
was it's this is this is this as an
example I know from a navigation
navigation perspective virtually
everything navigates to some place that
makes sense whoo it's just a really cute
really really polished really well done
game yeah you know you'd expect nothing
less from hot head is a is a very
well-established developer you know they
did deathspank they did see stars it did
they've got their new big wins fourth
series coming I mean they do a lot of
this stuff they came over from xbox and
playstation there yeah there's a word
they're they're they're they're great
guys and and this was this is a really
fun title III and I wish them the best
on this one so you don't have to be this
polished you don't have to be this
professional to be successful on Android
um but number yeah this is like this is
a good game yeah it really really is so
thanks for thanks to the high head guys
for nominating it and and of course
we're riding and bringing it to Google
Play it's always it's always a pleasure
and so that's why we wanted to save that
for last so hope some of those look with
us through our through our kind of
exciting technical day but I thought we
didn't that we didn't have a reboot we
did not forget that yeah we are pulling
ahead ass right and I don't know were we
boring we were probably boring probably
yeah but you know it's funny because we
had one guy say that we're awesome and
we had another guy commenter I can't
remember their their alias but youtube
commenter who said
don't take this the wrong way but you
guys are really boring that's true yeah
we can find it where people or people so
what that's not gonna tell us is how
should I take that what would be the
right way to take that please don't me
understand that oh well oh it's why I
you know some people would call that
constructive criticism you know it is
considered a shock point is we just
don't ya there anymore aw don't be
boring yes well we did take the phone
parts off the microphones yes so they
love on things anymore people people
were annoying noting that the
windshields on our honor of microphone
there's so many more a towel last time
and intended you know yeah there was
talla de tous that that was justified
that's very true but and any was the i
was the other guy who did that that's
true exactly yeah the one with the beard
right under the bears excellent ok you
guys know how this works if you nominate
your app on our moderator page which we
post a link every week if you don't know
where it is you just scroll back in our
G+ stream and Android developers and
you'll find it if you nominate your app
and it gets voted up by our by the
members of the public anyone can vote on
our moderator page you making it about
the top five or six apps will take a
look at it on this show and if we like
it enough we'll pass it along to the
editorial board and see if we can get
you featured in the Google Play Store
now yeah it'd be great also you know for
all of you people out there who are just
voting things down you know do consider
actually voting things up every once in
a while you know it seems like there's a
course of people who just love to kids
it's not as bad as it was though I think
people figured out that actually down
votes don't count very much no it's a
really don't but but you know really
vote up the things that you like I think
that's the most important thing and if
you're a really good reason for
downloading it leave a comment because
you know that's we know we want to know
you know I know this game was spammy we
didn't like the fact that it left a
process around all the time it stated
memory and it started you know doing all
sorts of things I didn't like it that
that that's a good reason to download it
make a comment explain why your dog
wedding is we want to know absolutely it
helps us in our review yep alright so
thanks everybody for participating
thanks very much for christian for
joining us and filling us in a little
bit on the
the cow cannon story and we will see you
next Friday for another Friday game
review